கேரலா, இந்த தேலென்று யார் சொல்லிக் கொடுத்து வந்தது, ஒரு கால அவர் அப்பா வந்து மூன்று வயதுல, இரண்டு வயதுல வயனின் பொம்மையை வாங்கிக் கொடுத்துக்கொள்ளலாம், அதை வந்து அவைக்கு வைத்து விளையாடியிருக்கலாம்,
அப்பா விளையாடியின் வயலின் வாசிக்கியவராக இருக்கலாம், அங்கே அவர் விளையாடியின் வாசிக்கியவருக்குள்ளே, இவர் கேட்டிருக்கலாம் அல்லது பார்த்திருக்கலாம்.
ஆனால் விளையாடியின் வாசிக்கியவராக இருக்கலாம் அல்லது கேட்டிருக்கலாம் அல்லது பார்த்திருக்கலாம் அல்லது விளையாடியின் வாசிக்கியவராக இருக்கலாம்.
அந்த விளையாடியின் வாசிக்கியவராக இருக்கலாம் அல்லது பார்த்திருக்கலாம்.
விளையாடியின் வாசிக்கியவராக இருக்கலாம் அல்லது பார்த்திருக்கலாம் அல்லது பார்த்திருக்கலாம்.
இந்த நாம் ஒன்று நாளுக்கு இருக்கும் பட்டம். பல வருடங்கள் பார்த்திருக்கிறோம்.
எப்படி அவனுக்கு இருக்கிறது? இப்போது அவளுடைய கர்மப்பலன் அதற்கு என்ன கர்மக்காரணம்?
நிச்சயமாக ஒன்று ஜன்மம், மறுபடியும் பிரப்பு என்பதுதான் நம் நாட்டில் நாம் வந்துள்ளோம். நிறைய நோயாகப் பிறக்கும் குழந்தை, இல்லது திரமச்சாலியாக இருக்கும் குழந்தை,
திடீரென்று சைக்கியே, மனப்பான்மே மாறி, லய்வே மாறிப்போற சிறு வயது, எதுவும் வயது, எத்தனையும் வழக்குகள். இதற்கு நிச்சயமாக மறுபடியும் பிரப்பு என்ற ஒரு விஷயத்திற்கு நம் நாட்டில் போயிருக்கிறார்கள்.
ஆனால் இந்த மறுபடியும் போயிருக்கிறது, சில சித்தர்கள், யோகிகள் நம் கண்ணாதை நிழுவித்திருக்கிறார்கள். நம் கண்ணாதை வாழ்ந்த சிலத்தில் அவருடைய வாழ்க்கையில் நிழுவித்திருக்கிறார்கள்.
அதைக்கூட நாம் அதையும் கேட்கிறோம், படிக்கிறோம், அவர் அடைந்திருக்கிறார் அந்த விஷயத்தில். இது ஒரு சம்மதாயத்தைக் கொண்டிருப்பதற்குப் பாபம், புண்ணியம், ஒரு சம்மதாயத்தைக் கொண்டிருப்பதற்குப் பாபம், புண்ணியம், ஒரு சம்மதாயத்தைக் கொண்டிருக்கிறார்கள்.
அதை வேண்டும் என்றால் சொல்லலாம், சம்மதாயத்தைக் கொண்டிருப்பதற்குப் பாபம் செய்தால், உனக்கு இந்த தண்டனை கிடைக்கும்.